let me begin by admitting we have a
connection I have a connection to final
space which is this project you made
this quite a while ago when you make the
first iteration of final space for
YouTube oh man 2011 yeah and it was
brought to my attention and I thought
this is fantastic
and so I wanted to see if we could bring
this to TBS and so I managed that can
producer on the show and a very very and
I'll tell you the minute I saw the show
I will never forget my two kids I have a
son and a daughter they both came out
and they sat down there in their 60s and
they sat down and they watch two
episodes with me and they immediately
and this is complicated for me they
liked it better than anything I've ever
done and this is you this is your vision
this is your show really I'm just here
to you know so yeah I I respect you but
also I have to admit there's some
jealousy and some content right now
you were you were on the forefront that
really the frontier of YouTube videos in
high school that's no not on the
forefront no way freaking I was on the
bottom front yo well nobody even watched
my videos like zero views well what I
didn't watch my video what I meant was
you were you were in on YouTube pretty
early on you weren't successful yes okay
yes let's make that clear yeah it took
you a while but someone told me that
when you were in high school you made a
video and you tried to get me to be the
voice on it I never heard about this but
yeah yeah I had a sketch comedy group
way back when in 2005 called balloon
shop and I wanted you to play this
character in a video and I insisted that
I thought if I wrote you the most
passionate letter just poured my guts
out into this note right that if I sent
it to you you would just do it and they
just said no no there's no freaking way
who's they the other guys in there yeah
really Wow and they just said no right
what was the money like there was zero
nothing no nothing that would not have
happened a comforting hug that would
never have had no no you never know you
never know you should have written a
letter you never know well I mean the
rule is perfect for you
I mean it was like this which a very
ghostly which a very long native finger
so it's a woman is what you're saying
well thanks a lot thanks a lot well I'm
telling you if you still want to do it
we can make it happen yeah it's
[Applause]
you